all right really this this this talk is
not actually intended to be about
cryptocurrencies it's it's about beyond
cryptocurrencies you know what if you
want to use blockchain for real-world
assets and you know like then I have
this problem that you know most of what
I work on a Stanford is my students very
excellent ideas including the next talk
that you'll see so it doesn't really
make sense for me to talk about my
students ideas but currently I'm on
leave and so I'm gonna tell you about
something that I'm doing not at Stanford
but then Stanford requires this
obligatory disclaimer here all right so
let's say that you wanted to send a
dollar from here in the United States to
a friend of yours in India
all right so if you try to do this with
today's banking system you'd find that
it probably takes like the better part
of a week to do this that to send your
$1 you'd probably be spending $20.00 in
fees it's likely that your friend in
India would probably be paying more than
$1 in fees to receive this international
wire and in fact this scenario is
preposterous right like nobody would
actually send $1.00 to India because
this is just like completely clunky and
ridiculous today so in an ideal world
this would be completely as simple as
easiest sending email right you just
stick a dollar into your computer and it
would pop up in India or maybe your
friend you know could get six you know
60 rupees or something out of out of out
of some bank in again it should be as
easy as sending email so the obvious
question you know is this a job for
blockchain right one of these magical
Satoshi's has come down and given us
this amazing gift of blockchain should
we be able to use this to send a dollar
to India well before we answer that
question there's just so much hype
around blockchain I think we should cut
through it and talk about what is
blockchain actually give us and really
it kind of boils down to three things so
the first thing that we get out of
blockchain is coin distribution how do
you invent some new coin out of thin air
like you know Bitcoin or you know or any
of these other coins distribute it to
people in such a way that there's a
limited supply of the coin but people
still believe it has value and that's
something that you know in 2008 seemed
kind of impossible and yet we've solved
that problem and boy does it generate a
lot of headlines right cuz you've all
these people who bought some asset for
like pennies and then it you know became
worth twenty thousand dollars or close
to it a few months ago yeah so that gets
a lot of attention the second thing
though is I think the even more
interesting aspect of blockchain and
that is that what blockchain gives you
is it gives you a reversible
transactions even with parties you don't
necessarily know or or trust right so
that's what allows me to walk up to you
like we've never met before we don't
trust one another I can give you some
digital coin and you can give me some
physical real-world asset that I can
walk away with because you're confident
that that digital transaction is not
going to be reversed and then that's
kind of the third benefit that we get
out of out of blockchain
are kind of a whole set of purely
incidental benefits that didn't really
require any scientific breakthroughs
right so this would be for example like
blockchain works 24/7 unlike the stock
market that only works during certain
hours or you know credit card numbers
are terrible they're just numbers it'd
be better if they were public keys but
you know and blockchain gives you like
public keys naming your accounts which
is kind of convenient probably the one
that has also gotten the most attention
is the regulatory differences that you
get from blockchain because it kind of
breaks all the rules it creates a lot of
regulatory uncertainty and so it's kind
of allowed people to innovate sort of
you know Airbnb or uber style in areas
that were you know probably over
regulated but regulated for a reason and
so what we really need in the long term
is of course to harmonize regulation
across you know blockchain and non
blockchain kind of things so I think you
know numbers one and three have really
gotten all the attention but the super
interesting one is is number two and
I'll get to why a little bit later on so
okay so why do we a blockchain well
because of this this paper on Bitcoin a
few years ago that basically had this
insight that we can solve problem number
one and problem number two at the same
time in a mutually reinforcing way using
this technique called
mining okay so what is my name
well mining is basically obtaining new
cryptocurrency as a reward for making
other people's digital transactions
harder to reverse and the mining
technique that's you know most popular
these days is called proof of work and
that's obviously the one that the
Bitcoin uses and and in aetherium and
the idea is you solve this kind of hard
search problem that's a function of the
entire history of transactions plus a
new batch of transactions you want to
commit and it's very hard to solve that
search problem but once you've found a
solution it's very easy for everyone to
verify it so you sort of put a whole
bunch of work into searching for a
blockchain that solves these constraints
and if you wanted to reverse
transactions you'd have to do it as much
work as all the good guys have done to
create an alternate blockchain but you
know those guys got rewarded and maybe
you won't get rewarded so you won't be
incentivized to do that there's other
forms of mining like instead of
computation there's proof of storage and
proof of memory and then there's also
proof of stake where you know in one way
or another you you kind of use your
coins to people you know your clout
depends on how many coins you have and
that you use that to to influence what
the next set of transactions will be but
they all basically boil down to to
mining okay so as I said you know I
think the most interesting thing about
blockchain is these irreversible
transactions and where that gets even
more interesting is when you have
multiple kinds of token on the same
blockchain and you can trade between
them right so let's come back to this
example where I wanted to send a dollar
to my friend in India maybe I'm at the
US and bank 1 my friends at at bank 4
here in India and maybe bank 4 has a
bank account at another bank bank 3 in
Europe these are called nostro accounts
when a bank is accountant in another
bank and make four might say hey if you
had 93 euro cents to my accountant bank
3 all gives whoever you want you know 60
rupees that at my branch in in India you
know maybe there's some other bank bank
too that has accounts at both bank 1 or
bank 3 and bank 2 says hey I'll I'll
trade you you know if you give me a
dollar to Mike
Bank one I'll give you you know 93 Euro
cents at Bank 3 and so what you could do
is with a block 10 you could pack this
all together into an atomic transaction
and execute this transaction and
actually change your dollar into rupees
without trusting any of the intermediary
parties like you'd like bank 2 right and
so in order to make this work what you
use for banks to issue tokens that
represent claims on deposits like in you
know dollars euros and and rupees and
then the ability to execute these
irreversible atomic transactions so this
is a very compelling example but there's
something interesting here which is that
I haven't used cryptocurrency at all
notice that there's no no Bitcoin or
aetherium or anything in this picture
right these are just currency backed
tokens that have been issued by these
regulated counterparties right because
they're banks and you know we trust our
banks to be solvent because we have a
whole bunch of infrastructure around
making sure that our banks are are
solvent and and and responsible okay so
currency is is one of many examples of
useful tokens issued by known
counterparties that might be useful to
trade on a blockchain so another would
be say like Kickstarter style rewards
right you know I go to Kickstarter I
spend five hundred dollars to fund some
you know special foldable canoe right
and that entitles me in a year to get
one of these foldable canoes if the
project is successful so that's
effectively a future for this product
that's that's gonna come out wouldn't it
be great if there were a secondary
market for the future and if in three
months I decide I don't want the canoe
anymore I could you know sell that
future to somebody else right well you
can do that if the asset that you got in
exchange for investing in this canoe
project was on a blockchain that
contained other assets like dollars and
you could trade for those assets other
examples would be like certificates of
authenticity for art or safety critical
parts you know any kind of securities
like stocks bonds mutual funds you know
obviously we're used to tokens for
transit rides you know cell phone
minutes
there's a famous kind of economics paper
on babysitting script and what goes
wrong if you don't have enough supply of
it but you know that obviously you could
do on this you know prediction markets
whatever you can think of the fact is
that if you can issue these assets on a
blockchain if you can tokenize them an
issue and I'm watching and the
blockchain gives you irreversible
transactions then kind of for free you
get a secondary market in any kind of
asset that you issue okay so what's the
problem well the problem is that block
chains can fork so in July of 2016
theorem which is like the second biggest
blockchain executed this weird kind of
irregular state change they were just
kind of hard-coded into the thing now
what happened well basically what
happened was that there'd been this
contract called the Dow and there was a
bug in the down because of that Dow
people lost fifty million dollars which
at the time was a lot in the blockchain
space right and so basically everybody
said oh this is this sucks you know we
wish this bug hadn't been there you know
if only we could go back in time and
like fix this bug and so 85% of the
miners said basically okay here's what
we'll do we'll just kind of change the
rules and make up this special one-time
rule to basically bail out this Dow
contract and reverse the effects of of
this unfortunate bug and so 85% of the
etherion miners decided to go ahead with
this weird change and execute it the
other 15% said hey wait a second you
know the rules are the rules like you
know it sucks that there was this bug
but like you know people aren't going to
trust this is it feel we're gonna make
up the rules as we go along so we're
gonna keep going under the original set
of rules and that branch of the
blockchain became aetherium classic more
recently there was a dispute in the
Bitcoin space where there's one set of
people who wanted to basically do this
thing called segregated witness which
was probably a good idea objectively
although there were some issues and how
they did it there was another set of
people who said you know what we really
want is more transactions per second so
we need to make the block size bigger
also they were probably motivated by the
fact that Segway defeated some mining
zatia no some people were done using so
well you had was big coin on one hand
and then this kind of fork that shared a
same prefix in the history as Bitcoin
called Bitcoin cash and you know if you
think that's kind of a dumb idea and you
don't like Bitcoin cash or maybe you
don't like Bitcoin you you know if you
had a Bitcoin before and now you have
one Bitcoin plus one Bitcoin cash so you
know you could turn around and sell your
Bitcoin cash for $600 say today and you
know who are you to complain you just
got a free $600 right it's kind of like
if you had a company and the company
spun off a subsidiary even you got stock
in the parent company and the subsidiary
you could sell either one of the two but
the problems what would this mean for
token issuers right suppose that your
bank and you issue dollars on to the
etherium network in say like June of
well now you potentially face twice as
many Redemption requests right because
you've got the same number of dollars on
the etherium and the etherium classic
blockchain right and this is clearly a
very bad right you don't want to face a
lot liabilities for twice as many
digital dollars as you've issued so the
moral of the story here is that mining
is actually pretty scary for digital
asset issuers right I mean first of all
mining is anonymous right all it means
is that somebody with sufficient
resources has you know executed the the
computation to extend or fork the
history and you know so far we've been
kind of lucky in with a high profile
Forks have been kind of announced in
advance and each has been assigned a
separate name like aetherium and
etherion classic but you could imagine
you know a branch where it's just like -
a fork where it's like - different you
know competing pools of miners who are
kind of duking it out and saying hey
everybody join our mining pool because
then we'll give you more rewards and if
this goes on for a while and they're
both playing under the same rules and
the mining is anonymous you can't even
name the two different Fork so how are
you gonna say like who's allowed to
redeem your tokens that you've issued
and who isn't another problem is that
the mining rewards themselves might
actually be provide insufficient
incentive for securing your transaction
so even on the biggest block chains like
big coin and if there
the mining rewards today are under ten
million dollars a day which is dwarfed
by you know the number of you know the
amount of sort of dollars letters like
trillions of dollars moving between
banks on a daily basis right and it's
kind of worse is that now there's like
Bitcoin futures you can trade so if
you're a miner and you're about to do
something really weird you can actually
heads yourself against the damage you're
going to do to Bitcoin by selling a
bunch of Bitcoin futures right and and
then you can kind of recall kinds of
having you know because there might be
non-financial kind of extrinsic
incentives to do this right let's say
you're a forward-looking company and you
say hey I'm gonna issue my stock on
Bitcoin by using you know colored coins
to represent my shares and now my stock
can be traded on a blockchain and then
you do some high profile deal with
Taiwan and next thing you know like
weird things are happening to your stock
sales they're getting reversed and
whatever and well you know nobody's come
out and threatened you but you know that
there are a lot of miners in China and
like you know this is just would be a
very uncomfortable situation to be in
okay so the Morla story here is we have
to protect asset issuers from Forks in
the blockchain and so the obvious idea
here is why don't you require whoever is
issuing an asset to endorse all the
transactions in that asset right after
all you know the issuer is a
counterparty to these digital tokens so
they should you know be allowed to know
you know who's transferring the money
and make sure that it's not that the the
coins aren't getting duplicated so you
could kind of call this the the PayPal
model right you've got this centrally
managed ledge or like PayPal keeping
track of who has all these tokens and
obviously PayPal doesn't face the threat
of double claims on Redemption because
because everything happens through them
but if we went to a world with kind of a
thousand PayPal estrella you know you
have a PayPal for your transit rides of
PayPal for your cellphone minutes of
PayPal you know for each of these things
the problem is that you then can't trade
across these different PayPal's right so
this rules out even basic forex trading
and I would argue that most of the kind
of the most compelling applications of
watching involve introducing new token
types and being able to transact have
atomic transactions that involve
multiple different token types so the
idea that we had with stellar which is
not
profit I'm involved with is what if we
have many issuers issuing tokens but all
on one ledger however each issuer is
going to define tokens in such a way as
to prevent double claims and so what
we're gonna do is we're going to have
the issuers each issuer is going to
designate a validator Authority who is
kind of authoritative for one portion of
the ledger namely the holdings and that
issuers tokens right and then all the
different validators are going to
cooperate to maintain the single global
ledger but if history did four there'd
be no ambiguity as to you know which
version of a ledger was authoritative
for for which token type because you've
kind of declared that in advance and
these validators they're known parties
are not anonymous at all they're things
like banks or you know big companies
like IBM for example so the idea here is
that well we already trust the token
issuers to remain solvent and to be
willing to redeem tokens because that's
what gives the tokens value so why don't
we also trust the token issuers to make
the transactions irreversible and in
order to do this we need to make well so
kind of the idea here would be that
imagine that you know you only can agree
that a transaction happens when all the
sort of counterparties you care about do
so if you're interested in cashing out
dollars at bank one and rupees at bank
four then you'll say like hey I'm only
gonna agree to a transaction when you
know my bank in San Francisco and this
other Bank here in Mumbai India have
both agreed that this has happened but
these banks deal with other banks right
and so they're not going to agree that a
transaction has happened until the banks
that they depend on agree that's happen
who also will depend on other banks and
so on until you kind of take the
transitive closure of these dependency
relations and eventually the whole world
has agreed that this transaction has
happened and so at this point once
everybody's agreed it becomes very hard
to roll this back and even if if you
remember in the example I had Bank two
we didn't know who it was but it was
offering us a good rate getting from
dollars to euros and so it banked to
somehow Desai's the transaction didn't
happen but the whole rest of the world
does well who cares you know because in
the end of the day you don't care about
cashing anything in it bank - and so
bank - could just be in its own weird
little fork of the world or if it wants
to exist and continue to exist in the
banking system it will have to agree
that that this has happened so so in
order to make this happen we need one
assumption and this is something that I
call the internet hypothesis right so
the Internet is this globally connected
network but what's interesting is that
there's no central authority that's
dictating the structure of the internet
right instead basically the Internet is
the reason out of these pairwise
relationships between networks that
entrant appearing and transit agreements
right and so of course this
decentralized and peering structure
could have resulted in multiple
different Internet's but it didn't right
it resulted in this one network that we
call the Internet and the reason is that
sort of transitively everybody wants to
talk to everyone right I may not know
who you are but you know I want to talk
to say Google and you want to talk to
Google or I want to talk to somebody who
wants to talk to Google and so on if you
take sort of that the transitive
convergence of everybody people want to
talk to you'll get kind of a lot of
overlap so the hypothesis here is that
counterparty relationships in in these
tokens are actually you know have the
same kind of a transitive convergence
right so you have banks dealing with
correspondent banks dealing with
clearing houses and essentially these
clearing houses are gonna be like the
tier 1 ISPs of payments so using this
idea we can define a new kind of
consensus protocol that I call federated
Byzantine agreement and the idea is
based on Byzantine agreement which is a
known technique for achieving consensus
amongst a closed group of nodes but the
problem with classic Byzantine agreement
is that a basis security on this notion
of of majorities right are super
majorities right so so it's vulnerable
that this attack called the civil attack
where you say hey any like 2/3 plus 1 of
nodes constitute of quorum and so a bad
guy comes in and creates you know a
hundred fake nodes that are all controls
and so it overwhelms the number of good
nodes so the idea is we're gonna defeat
these civil attacks by choosing quorum
composition in a decentralized way and
this will be much less
symmetric but it'll depend on the actual
trust that people place in the entities
in the system so this works
each node V is gonna pick one or more
sets of nodes that we call quorum slices
and V basically picks as a quorum slice
any set of nodes that it considers
important enough to kind of speak for
the network as a whole right so the
choice is gonna be based on real-world
identities but in particularly if you
care about redeeming tokens issued by by
particular nodes you probably want to
put those nodes in all of your quorum
slices so given this idea we can define
a federated business in agreement system
as a set of nodes V and this quorum
function Q where Q of little V is the
set of places chosen by node V and now
we can define a quorum to be a set of
nodes U that is a that contains at least
one quorum slice of each of its members
so here's kind of a simple example I
have four nodes each one is a single
quorum slice and I'll visualize the
quorum slices by drawing an arrow from a
node to the other members of its quorum
slice right you can see that V one has a
quorum slice if you wanted B to be three
the other nodes have quorum slice to be
2 B 3 B 4 so if we consider V 2 V 3 for
this is trivially a quorum because it
says it contains it is every one of its
members quorum slices what about V 1 V 2
V 3
that's a quorum slice it's not a quorum
because we want to say I'll agree to
anything that V 2 and V 3 do but V 2 and
V 3 say we'll only agree to something if
V 4 does so the smallest quorum
including V 1 is actually the set of all
nodes in this example so here's a little
more realistic example have a kind of
tiered quorum slice structure
reminiscent of the internet where maybe
there's a top tier of quorum of
validators that depend on three out of
four each other and then maybe a middle
tier that depend on two out of four the
top tier maybe there's a leafed here but
like the internet there's gonna be no
central authority appointing the tier 1
validators instead it'll be left to
market choices and maybe a market
decides hey you know the top 4 retail
banks you know these are these are what
should constitute the the top tier
validators but you don't need complete
consensus on this so v7 and v8 might be
paranoid and they might say well we
realize we have to get with the big
banks but we don't trust them we also
want to depend
some nonprofits whose incentives are
differently aligned so they'll say well
wait for two out of four big banks to
sign off on our transactions but also
one out of these three nonprofits and
then on profits depend on two out of
three of each other okay so let's say
that this paranoia is well-founded
and Citibank walks up to v7 pays v7 a
billion dollars and says hey b7 I just
gave you a billion dollars we've got
this blockchain magic so you know it's
irreversible give me a billion dollars
worth of goods I'm gonna walk away with
them and you should feel secure that you
got your payment all right and so b7
says okay I need to out of these four
big banks got that I need one of these
nonprofits got that this nonprofit needs
them of a non-profit got that these guys
need three out of four got that good
everything is good now turns out the
paranoia is correct and these big banks
are evil so they collude to kind of
reverse the effects of this transaction
and then they walk up to VA and say hey
v-eight here's a billion dollars that
you know we shouldn't have because we
gave it to v8 but it sure looks like we
still have it so why don't you give us a
billion dollars but the goods will
quickly run away with that right and v8
says well I need two out of four big
banks check I also need one of these non
profits well stellar and AFF aren't
going to sign off on this right because
they know that the money now belongs to
b7 but maybe ACLU was kind of lagging
behind so v8 talks to the ACLU but the
ACLU depends on two out of these three
nonprofits so you see how you say well
sorry I'm not gonna believe this in this
unless one of these other nonprofits
signs off and that's not gonna happen
because the other nonprofits know this
isn't legitimate so those nodes will
basically protect the eight against this
double spend attack okay so basically I
designed this consensus protocol based
on this idea and it has some nice
properties like basically guarantees
safety when you have quorum intersection
after removing all the nodes that
deviate from the protocol and that's a
necessary property for safety in this
kind of model so what I've shown is is
also sufficient meaning that you know
basically SCP kind of provides optimal
safety so you might regret your choice
of quorum slices but you won't regret
choosing SCP over some other
consensus protocol it also guarantees
that a well-worn won't get stuck the
core idea and the protocol is this idea
of federated voting right nodes exchange
these vote messages but each vote
specifies the the senders or the voters
quorum slices and so as you collect
votes you can kind of dynamically
discover whether or not a set of nodes
constitutes a quorum so the way this
works is there's kind of two phases to
the protocol and the first phase you
have nodes nominating values until at
least one value has unless and until
they've agreed on nomination or at least
one value so here maybe let's say
they've everybody's they've agreed that
tx3 is nominated and then they kind of
continue to propagate values until they
converge and ultimately they will
converge on some set of nominated values
which they can combine in some
deterministic way and you can actually
show that it's they're guaranteed that
all nodes will eventually converge on
the same set of nominated values now
there's a catch here because of this
impossibility result in distributed
systems for consensus that they will
never know even though you're guaranteed
to converge you never know that you have
converged so you take your best guess
that the system is converging and you
move on to the second phase called
balloting which is similar to Byzantine
paxos if he if you know Paxos but it
uses federated voting right so basically
you prepare about it and you commit a
ballot and if everybody's converged in
the first round this would be fast and
and and easy and if not well it'll be a
little bit slower but it'll still be
guaranteed to be safe and it won't get
stuck so as long as the network behaves
eventually you'll you'll confirm some
value okay so so this algorithm is SCP
is in production use by this blockchain
called stellar it's like the eighth
largest blockchain today and we've got
actually we have a last night when I was
preparing these slides we had 106
validators participating in consensus
this morning I happen to check again on
the way and it's actually up to 108 so I
guess the the system is is growing and
they're achieving consensus every five
seconds and if there's no it's not
expensive to participate you just need
to compute a few digital signatures
every five seconds so we can you know
have it's it's much cheaper to
participate in the system it's an open
network in anyone can join but of course
merely joining doesn't mean that you're
gonna end up in other people's Quorum
slices right that happens when people
know based on your reputation that you
know they should they should depend on
you or that they want to depend on you
so we've seen all kinds of people
participate like there's big companies
like IBM the telephone companies you
know money transmittal organizations
universities there's a bunch of
different types of validators in there
and our primary use case today is for
international payments to make this much
cheaper and faster but we've seen all
kinds of other uses kind of emerged so
for example it's being used by coffee
futures by this company called Beck's
360 in-app currencies geological data
cryptocurrency baskets you know
basically you name it if you want to
issue a token and you want their
instantly lead to be a secondary market
for that token dollars a good platform
for that so compared to other approaches
you know you could try to use Byzantine
agreement over a closed server set and
say well these are the big banks these
are the people who should participate if
that actually happens what you probably
end up having happen is that a bunch of
kind of third parties would come and be
like auditing the performance of these
big banks to keep them honest and so
basically you kind of get a poor-man's
FBI anyway so you might as well kind of
do it right and get optimal safety from
the thing and of course you might also
be tempted to use to proof of work but
again then your consensus is integrally
tied up with coin distribution and these
incentives and if you know you're not
interested in generating new coins but
you want to just issue tokens back to
our real world value that's not
necessarily the best thing in fact the
incentives might prove insufficient or
ill-suited for the assets that you were
showing all right thanks
[Applause]
we have time for questions actually I'm
really curious in the so you have 100
yeah yeah I think what people choose is
a much smaller subset of those I think
of those 108 there's probably a most 30
that people actually depend on but like
I said it's all over the way so IBM has
like you know five of them or something
and all around the world
stellar obviously has like three of them
because we're the people putting this
out but yeah then there's like a telco
there's I mean you can't you can go to
what does its stellar have it linked in
the slides of some there's like various
websites that that that lists these I
was like - Linda does one that's it
that's a telco there's like tempo is
like issues these euro back tokens there
are money transmittal organization
there's yeah I'm not sure all kinds of
people basically
of the effect of yeah I mean I think
this is a this is a big problem with
with the proof-of-work stuff it's not
there's not it's not an issue in stellar
because you know as an issue or you
you're protected I mean you're you're
the one issuing the tokens so you know
basically you could so so yeah so if
you're concerned about bribes then you
definitely would want to use something
like stellar and run a validator
yourself such that you could you could
guarantee that you know no funny
transactions go through that you don't
approve and nothing gets rolled back hi
you said well not eight notes right so
those notes getting any notes are
getting any benefits like token or
anything by joining it no it's more like
why do you run a mail server instead of
telling all of your employees to use
Gmail or something because you know it's
not that expensive and you want some
control you know it's it's convenient to
like have control over it so it's that
mining Bitcoin is hugely expensive right
running a stellar validator yeah you
need like a computer and you know you
know few gigs of memory or whatever but
it's not it's not particularly onerous
right you do it for the control mainly
brewpub work as an old than anything
else you know there is no proof of work
you were digitally signing a message
saying like yes I agree that this is the
next batch of transactions so it's it's
very cheap to run a validator and what
you get is the ability to protect
yourself against double spans because
you tell people you're dealing with hey
the transaction hasn't gone through
until my validator has signed off on it
and my validator won't sign off until
all the people I consider important have
signed off on it
there is you do not you do not make
money as a validator there are there's a
small transaction
fee for just anti-spam reasons but that
goes into like an inflation pool we do
not reward validators any more than we
don't reward mail servers right like you
run a mail server because it's
convenient for you to have email and
because it's not that expensive you
don't run it because you get mining
rewards or anything so that's that's our
model and but it's proving to work out
right because a lot of people they want
a copy of the ledger state anyway so
they might as well run a validator or
they're issuing a token and they want to
protect themselves against double spend
attacks example I build the data
distributor application on top of seller
so let's my algorithm say is that I
distribute 30% of the data across the
validator or not eight nodes they are
storing my data but they are not gaining
anything so you have any restrictions on
stellar like you can yeah so there's
there's a native currency which is sort
of counterparty free and there's a
minimum balance in an account in that
currency and that minimum balance is
proportional to how much ledger state
you are taking up unlike a UT exobase
blockchain like Bitcoin we can truncate
history you don't have to keep the whole
history so you can actually reduce the
amount of state and get back to your
minute your minimum balance but but
basically like it boils down to yes
there's anti-spam protections to make it
expensive to consume a huge amount of
state in the ledger
[Applause]
you